lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
abordar el tema del tamaño de la célula
muy bien vamos a abordar el tema del
tamaño de
célula ok vamos a abordar este tema y en
particular vamos a discutir qué tan
pequeñas pueden llegar a ser las células
y también discutir cuáles pueden ser
digamos algunos factores limitantes que
restringen qué tan grande puede llegar a
ser una célula y tengo algunas imágenes
aquí por ejemplo en esta imagen de la
derecha tenemos una una célula
bacteriana esta es una célula bacteriana
cada una de estas digamos estructuras
que tienen forma de píldora es una
célula bacteriana y algo muy interesante
que tienen estas células es que tienen
digamos un ancho o un grosor digamos de
aproximadamente un micrómetro aunque
tienen un micrómetro de ancho muy bien
ahora también otra cosa interesante que
podemos notar aquí es que la longitud
digamos o el largo que tienen estas
píldoras es de aproximadamente 5
micrómetros que quizás ahí no se ve muy
bien pero esto es aproximadamente de 5
micrómetros muy bien y recordemos un
micrómetro es una millonésima parte de
un metro o si quieres puedes
visualizarlo de otra forma como que es
una milésima parte de un milímetro
verdad quizás eso te sirva mucho más
para distinguirlo ahora bien por ejemplo
del lado izquierdo tenemos otro tipo de
células estas son células que pueden que
se pueden hallar en el cuerpo humano por
ejemplo aquí tenemos un glóbulo rojo y
este glóbulo rojo tiene digamos un
diámetro aproximado de 7 micrómetros muy
bien este tiene un diámetro de 7
micrómetros aquí por ejemplo tenemos una
célula blanca
esta célula digamos redonda que tenemos
aquí es una célula blanca y tiene una
escala muy similar digamos a la de la
célula roja ok y bueno por ejemplo
podemos observar otro tipo de células
aquí pero bueno todas tienen una escala
muy
comparable verdad en esta otra imagen
tenemos un espermatozoide humano que
está a punto de penetrar un óvulo muy
bien ahora bien los óvulos son son de
las células más grandes que podemos
hallar en el cuerpo humano de hecho
tienen una forma esférica por ejemplo si
continuáramos esta imagen del óvulo
podríamos ver que tiene una forma
esférica que hay más o menos el esférico
verdad y los óvulos suelen tener digamos
un diámetro aproximado de 100
micrómetros que entonces si te das
cuenta es mucho más grande que estas
bacterias o que estas otras células y
está bien que todas las fotos se
encuentren digamos casi a la misma
escala pero pero la primera pregunta que
nos podemos plantear es la siguiente qué
tan pequeña puede ser una célula y si lo
pensamos bien digamos una célula es es
un ser vivo es sumamente complejo de
poseer información verdad a través del
adn se debe poder replicar de tener una
maquinaria metabólica es bastante
verdad así que por ejemplo he leído que
la célula más pequeña que se conoce es
del orden de 100 nanómetros y recordemos
que 1000 nanómetros sería exactamente un
micrómetro verdad que justamente es el
ancho de esta bacteria que tenemos aquí
así que por ejemplo si quisiéramos
pintar esta célula que es la más pequeña
que se conoce verdad más o menos sería
digamos de este tamaño ahí tendríamos
nuestra célula más pequeña que se conoce
verdad y de hecho algunos investigadores
han propuesto que esta célula puede
llegar a ser la cota inferior o una cota
inferior para el tamaño de una célula
y recordemos una célula debe tener una
maquinaria genética debe tener
maquinarias metabólicas así que no puede
ser tan chica verdad pero ahora por otro
lado podemos preguntarnos qué ocurre con
la cota superior es decir qué tan grande
puede llegar a ser una célula y un
factor limitante es la proporción que
existe entre el volumen y la superficie
ahora uno se puede preguntar bueno por
qué tiene que ser tan importante es esa
digamos ese factor verdad entonces
pensemos por ejemplo que tenemos una
célula digamos que es esta es una célula
esférica muy bien tenemos una célula
esférica y recordemos que la superficie
esencialmente es digamos la la frontera
verdad del área que ocupa la frontera de
esta célula entonces por ejemplo digamos
la superficie lo que lo que detecta es
la entrada de los nutrientes verdad y
también tiene que procesar la salida de
los desechos así que en cada digamos
unidad
de área de esta de estas células de la
superficie de esta célula debe procesar
la entrada y la salida de sustancias
verdad cada unidad de área procesa de
esas entradas y salidas para digamos
para un volumen dado ahora bien a medida
que la célula crece el volumen tiene que
crecer más rápido que la superficie
verdad de hecho a medida que crece cada
unidad de área ya no podría manejar
tanta entrada de nutrientes y tanta
salida de desechos si esta célula crece
demasiado al menos o al menos no podría
manejar lo suficientemente rápido verdad
así que para hacer todos estos
argumentos más tangibles veámoslo con un
poquito de matemáticas así que pensemos
que esta célula es esférica vamos a
darle sus digamos una noción de tres
dimensiones y digamos que tiene un radio
r muy bien así que si nosotros queremos
calcular el volumen de esta esfera eso
se calcula con la siguiente fórmula
verdad cuatro tercios de pi
el radio al cubo ahora si queremos
calcula calcular perdón la superficie de
esta esfera
tendría que ser 4 pi por el radio al
cuadrado estas son fórmulas que
conocemos para el volumen y el área de
la superficie de esta esfera verdad
entonces qué pasa si nosotros calculamos
la proporción que hay entre el volumen y
la superficie bueno pues esto
simplemente lo podemos sustituir verdad
esto será cuatro tercios de pi por el
radio al cubo dividido entre la
superficie que será 4 y r cuadrada y
esto para suerte nuestra es fácil de
calcular verdad 4 entre 4 se hace uno y
entre pi se hace una verdad y r cúbica
entre r cuadrada en realidad sólo nos
queda r verdad y entonces nuestra
fórmula final del para la proporción
entre el volumen y la superficie será r
entre 3 verdad es decir el radio
dividido entre 3 bueno en términos de
unidades por ejemplo si quisiéramos
hacer
claros serían unidades cúbicas entre
unidades cuadradas verdad y en realidad
no importa qué unidades estamos hablando
podríamos hablar de micrómetro dos
milímetros en fin de lo que sea ok
entonces vamos a utilizar esto que hemos
descubierto para pensar qué ocurre si
las células se vuelve cada vez más
grande así que por ejemplo consideremos
esta célula blanca de la que hablábamos
hace unos minutos verdad y digamos que
esta célula blanca tiene un radio de
vamos a ponerlo con un color que se vea
tiene un radio de 3 micrómetros verdad
más o menos es un radio de 3 micrómetros
muy bien entonces si nosotros calculamos
la proporción que hay entre el volumen y
la superficie pues eso nos dice que es
el radio dividido entre 3 pero el radio
son 3 micrómetros verdad dividido entre
3 y eso nos da nos da perdón exactamente
1 entonces las unidades que hay que
considerar si digamos vamos a escribirlo
así van a ser micrómetros cúbicos que es
la del volumen dividido entre
micrómetros cuadrados que son las
unidades del área verdad y eso nos está
diciendo algo muy importante digo si lo
simplificamos nos da simplemente
micrómetros pero esta expresión nos dice
algo muy importante nos dice cada micro
metro cuadrado tiene que manejar un
micro metro cúbico así que si por
ejemplo aquí tenemos un micro metro
cuadrado eso maneja un micro metro
cúbico de la célula verdad ahora ven
ahora bien vamos a vamos a teorizar un
poco vamos a hacer una teoría qué
pasaría si tuviéramos una célula mucho
más grande que esto verdad qué pasaría
si tuviéramos digamos una célula digo no
lo voy a pintar a la escala adecuada así
que vamos a pintar
solo una célula más grande verdad ahí
tenemos una célula más grande y digamos
que ahora el radio de esta célula fuera
de 3000 micrómetros es decir es mil
veces más grande que nuestra digamos
célula blanca verdad y esto recordemos
que 3000 micrómetros no es algo muy
exagerado simplemente serían tres
milímetros ok y por supuesto que esta
célula sería visible al ojo humano de
hecho se estima que el límite digamos de
la visibilidad humana es de 100
micrómetros que justamente coincide con
el diámetro de esta de esta célula que
es un óvulo verdad entonces de hecho 100
micrómetros son exactamente una décima
parte de un milímetro entonces más o
menos podrías ver lo digamos en una
regla verdad este sería limitado el
límite de la visibilidad humana digamos
un óvulo sería apenas visible para el
ojo humano entonces si nosotros tenemos
esta célula mucho más grande cuál sería
la proporción entre él
y la superficie bueno pues esa
proporción sería el radio dividido entre
3 que sería 3000 verdad 3000 micrómetros
dividido entre 3 y eso simplemente nos
da 1000 micrómetros verdad serían 1000
micrómetros mil micro metros cúbicos /
micro metros cuadrados es decir cada
unidad de área cada micro metro cuadrado
tiene que manejar mil mil micro metros
cúbicos verdad ahora tiene que manejar
mucho más volumen si aquí teníamos
digamos nuestro micro metro cuadrado
ahora tiene que manejar muchísimo
muchísimo más volumen que antes cierto
entonces ahora no va a poder
intercambiar los nutrientes o los gases
o los desechos suficientemente rápido
como para que la célula funcione
adecuadamente así que la proporción
entre el volumen y la superficie es un
factor muy importante para las células y
podríamos ver otras proporciones
interesantes por ejemplo
cómo se relaciona con la masa o con otro
tipo de cosas pero bueno digamos vamos a
quedarnos con esta proporción la
proporción entre volumen y superficie
que es bastante interesante verdad
entonces otro factor importante digamos
es que a medida que la célula crece el
transporte debe atravesar de distancias
más largas por supuesto el transporte de
sustancias verdad y esto puede volverse
un verdadero problema de hecho la razón
por la que hemos hablado principalmente
de células esféricas es porque puede
haber células más largas
células más largas como por ejemplo las
células nerviosas por ejemplo digamos
tenemos aquí una
en una caricatura digamos de una célula
célula nerviosa verdad que tiene ahí
está digamos esta parte y digamos tiene
esta otra que se puede ver así verdad
entonces esta es una célula nerviosa y
estas células nerviosas tienen la
característica de ser más largas y más
delgadas verdad y de esta forma están
maximizando la superficie pero bueno no
tendrían nada más que ser así por
ejemplo podríamos pensar en células que
a lo mejor tengan estas estructuras que
salen digamos de ellas verdad y quizás
de esta forma están maximizando también
la superficie verdad así que las células
no siempre tienen que ser esféricas pero
en general en general modelar las
células como una esfera no es
necesariamente una locura y además
podemos ver por qué las células humanas
si las modelamos como una esfera no
tienden a pasar el tamaño de un óvulo